hello everyone and welcome to round 2 of
the world rapid championship it's
Armenian Grandmaster trunk knocked me on
vs. magnus carlsen two of them already
played against each other and last time
they played Carlson was in serious
trouble and he managed to get out of it
and and win the game in Indian so let's
see what happens this time and like the
title suggests it could be it could be
very dangerous so the game just finished
her I thought why why not why not show
it right away
so Hannah knocked me on witted white
pieces opens with d4 now with Knight to
f6 by Magnus c4 and East 6 Knight to f3
we have d5 Knight to c3 and well
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined and now c5 the semi tirage
prepare well about to play the famous
dubov line that he will usually plays we
have C capture Sun b5e cat person d5 and
the g3 we have Knight to c6 Bishop to g2
and now C captures on d4 Knight cap for
Sundy 4 and now Bishop to c5 then he'll
do both signature move where he where he
got Sun they're very nice games and well
a lot of wins all he did lose one very
interesting game to her the Hikaru
Nakamura I would with Bishop to c5 but
ok we have Knight captures by milkman B
captures and c6 and here just castles
Magnus also castles and now Queen to c2
developing the Queen also the Bishop on
c5 is being x-rayed so Magnus
immediately removes it we have nice day
for going after the bishop and now there
is one game where Bishop the b7 was
played but here magnets goes Bishop to
d7 and it is as of mu 12 that we have a
completely new game so we have Knight
captures and b6 we have a capture son b6
improving his pawn structure also
getting a semi-open file for the rook
but now before a very important move as
it prevents cousin from pushing c5 and
well as long as this point is in c6 it's
a backwards upon it's a weak bone and
it's going to be a liability for a very
long time so Carlsen doesn't want to
allow a free a4 so he pushes beef
now accepting that this is going to be a
problem for for quite some time now and
now well although you can play a four
but then just everything gets traded
captures captures captures captures in
the black doesn't really have any
problems here so we have Bishop to b2 by
Malcolm Yan we have looked it by Magnus
and now III we have h5 four hoping to
get some age for action and maybe in
some later parts of the game and now
Queen to c3 not allowing the Knights to
move due to the threat of Queen to g7
mate
and here you have to continue
development you can choose between
something like Queen to e7 or Queen to
see eight which Magnus chooses the idea
is Bishop to h3 to swap off the light
square bishop we have rook F to d1 here
Malcolm young is interested in going for
a nice rock left here D f4 is a dark
square
Magnus doesn't have a dark square bishop
so it should be it should be fairly safe
there
unless Magnus is willing to open up the
position with the g5 but okay with
Bishop the h3 as planned and now white
declines the trade and goes bush up to
h1 saying that my bishop is going to be
more useful and there aren't all that
many ways you can take advantage of it
although as long as this structure holds
the light square bishop will not be able
able to do much about it so Queen the f5
by Magnus getting the Queen their game
and rook to d4 going for rook to f4 and
here Magnus continues with the rook the
e6 now the c6 point is nicely nicely
guarded and also at some point if if
white maybe decides to bring the other
rook into the game we had the D file
then you can double up here although we
don't really want to move this rook you
kind of need to keep an eye on the a
Foursquare but here I will just show it
because it's really interesting there is
a rookie for where you can just say okay
I'm really interested in trading rooks
here because if Bishop captures then
have 2d characters this well the threat
of the queen of three to g2 mate is just
great so here what would have to play f4
e captors on f4 on pass on rook to f4
now f2 check King captures sorry well
King captures and then 94 check
four to the king and the Queen and the
rook cannot capture or even better after
F to check if rook captures you just
play Queen captures an f2 King captures
94 check Forge the king and the Queen
King f3 you capture here characters and
the material on the board is equal but
you know it's a it's something that what
both words would definitely calculate if
this was a classical game but it's rapid
I don't really have time white will be
unable to use the D file but white wants
to push a for either way so black is
it's very unlike that black will move
the rook from the from the a file so
should be should be around equal
although white has a very active King
but okay
after rugby for Magnus goes for Rookie
six we have looked the F for now pushing
the Queen back and Queen to g6 and here
a three by Malkina milkman doesn't want
a lot well Knights the e4 is coming it
will come with an attack on the Queen
but you don't want to play Queen to d4
otherwise
well you get a rook captures an a2 and
now after rook captures Queen B one
queen blocks and Queen captures is just
checkmate so a milkman of course wants
to avoid any ideas of blonde during the
game like that a three-night efore by
Magnus and now Queen to d4 just keeping
the Queen on this very strong diagonal
we have Knight back to d6 by Magnus and
now comes Bishop to f3 now introducing
some very nice threats to the position
but milkman is a very long time well not
very long he's some five minutes on the
clock whereas Magnus is 10 minutes on
the clock but he already has the threat
of Bishop captures and h5 where you will
be unable to capture because the Queen
has to keep an eye on the mate on g7 so
here Magnus played f6 and this will
create a lot of problems for him now
best works Queen to h6 actually because
now if you try Bishop captures on h5
with the same idea then you have Knight
to f5 attacking the Queen also your
garden mate so it's not a problem now
capturing the bishop really is a threat
but even better after Queen to d1
defending the bishop now you have g5 and
the rook will have to move well there is
no good square for the rook you will
have to give up the rook for for a night
here and ok whatever white white can
still play this of course he has the
best repair and
he shouldn't be worse here but that was
the best course of action for Magnus
Queen to h6 here but okay we have f6
the position from the thumbnail is
reached and now comes a move that really
puts a lot of problems in front of
Magnus so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this move while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations it's not that difficult
of a move to find but when you're
playing a rapid game it's easy to miss
its Queen to d1 you just attack the h5
point and there's no way to defend it
you cannot push h4 because the room just
picks it up so it's really really
unpleasant position for Magnus so here
at Magnus lost a lot of time in the end
he decided to play Bishop to g4 now both
players are around five minutes with
Bishop characteris H captures and now
whitey decided to play rook captures on
g4 which is definitely the the correct
idea you have a better position you
control more space you want the Queen's
on the board so rook captures and g4 and
now Queen to f5 we look back to f4
pushing the Queen back Queen g6 and now
Bishop to d4 not allowing a nice to see
fourth account with an attack on the
bishop and also you control the c5
squared square a bit more we have looked
to e4 now offering a trader of rooks and
here Queen to c2 immediately joining the
action so recaptures is now impossible
to two Queen captures and g6 but also
there's the threat of f3 which just wins
the rook because the rook cannot move so
Queen back to e8 and only now Malcolm
entries rook captures we have Knight
captures and now King to g2 Knight back
to d6 Magnus wants to have halved this
efile free for his Queen to enter the
game and now while white should
definitely avoid pushing 8 4 and give
Magnus yeah well a free ideas off of how
to continue the game like I said it's a
rapid game time is low and he does push
a 4 probably playing on the Queen side
with the g4 h3 first improving the
position as much as possible would be
definitely preferred
but okay look character Sunday for we
have rook after Sunday for phone
captures and now queen cat for Sunday
for Magnus goes for Quinta efore check
we have f3 and now Queen to d3 Magnus
offers the c6 pawn and here not me on
got very long time he was around 30
seconds and in the end he decided to
continue the game by capturing the pawn
on c6 there are a lot of ways you can
continue the game well you could just go
Quinta AAA to check first you could go
Queen captures and see it you could try
and improve the position of your king
but all in all it's a pretty equal
position so here at Malcolm you play the
Queen captures on c6 now creating a very
strong passed pawn so Magnus cannot
allow this point to start marching
forward but then again he doesn't have
to because he has Queen to e to check
King G 1 and now Queen to be one with
check after King G 2 it was in this
position on move 30 39 that the players
agreed to a draw so once again against
milkman Magnus goes into into a worse
position but man is just you know to
climb on top here you you don't have any
chances of continuing this game somehow
because the knight is hanging there's
just a way to do anything here so around
to a draw and we're now gonna check out
some other games maybe we have time to
check out another one before round 3
starts so that yeah the game I do hope
you enjoyed it be very careful before
you play f6 because even if you're a
real champion it can it can definitely
go wrong I would like to thank dog McNab
Edward Baker maxime peace and entry and
1998 and torrents fight for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
rapid ambush championship for the next 5
days
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day